vous entendez cediv après ça tout le
reste les mondanités cocktails et robes
du soir les général et puis l'été la
côte d'azur saint tropez c'est
intolérable
il y en a ras-le-bol ras-le-bol
ras-le-bol cette année jean et moi on
n'en pouvait plus on a fui jusqu en
auvergne au fin fond du cantal une ferme
au bout d'un village d'une saleté d'une
beauté dément les femmes en noir sans
âge et dante est par contre encore des
seaux d'eau le visage creusé ravagé
sillonné comme la terre génitrice
convient de labourer les vieux paysan
immobile sur leur banc de pierre moussu
ne prononçant pas à un mot pendant des
journées entières lançant seulement de
temps à autre le jet de rues de leur
salive comme on jette sa semence
c'est d'un pathétique et d'une
authenticité souvent jean et moi de nous
regardions et nous disions mais c'est
pas possible ça existe encore mais c'est
merveilleux faut en profiter très vite
s'énerver merde
et puis un soir ce soir là je ne suis
pas prêt de l'oublier
jean est tombé dans le tas de fumier ou
barre le chemin conduisant à la ferme
je l'attendais j'étais à table comme une
chatte affamés je l'appelle et bourru en
écoutant la mélopée nostalgiques des
moutons ou venant du pâturage
lorsque jean est entré cette odeur cette
odeur j'ai dit à jean jetons supplie ne
fait pas un pas puis je le supporte pas
c'était trop trop d'un seul coup je me
suis levé mon coeur battait violemment
petit à petit je me suis approché de
joux je l'aimais longuement je crois
bien que j'ai pleuré j'ai dit à jean tu
te rends compte ya seulement huit jours
nos vêtements s'entête encore l'essence
la poussière la ville l'horreur et
maintenant tu sens mais si ça la vérité
jean mon chéri nous tenons la vérité
je t'ai fayet il m'a serré très fort
contre lui
il a posé sa main puis censure- ma krupp
il m'a dit viens une voix sourde et
animale il montrait mis dehors
je suis laissée happer par les clameurs
20 décembre de cette chaude nuit d'été
avec mes sabots ma longue robe pisano
coton bleu délavé jeu très dur c'est
dans la boue ils purent 1
c'était bon nous avons traversé l'écurie
va respirer ses senteurs il m'a semblé
que j'étais ivre
nous avons hâte à la grange dont il a
ouvert la porte il m'a poussé dans le
choix de tous poussés dehors dedans ceux
d'été comme nullement gémissements
allaitement de 16 ans quand nous nous
sommes revus mais j'en ai moi après deux
ou trois saillie n'a pas eu tout mêlé à
mes cheveux les faits et à nos toits
dans un team j'avais acquis une
certitude
à partir de cet instant plus rien ne
sera comme avant
désormais je ne pourrai plus faire
l'amour